[Music]
Beyonce opening up like never before
about her life body and heritage Queen B
looks like royalty rocking a flower
crown on one of her two covers for Vogue
September issue which proudly proclaims
everyone's voice counts inside the
singer who reportedly had full creative
control over the cover her fourth with
the mag gets personal about her life as
a superstar mom it's no secret that the
flawless singer seemingly had the best
snapback ever after giving birth to her
first child blue ivy but she says quote
I put pressure on myself to lose all the
baby weight in three months and
scheduled a small tour to assure I would
do it looking back that was crazy after
weighing in at 218 pounds while pregnant
with twins sir and roomie
Beyonce admits she now feels more
beautiful sexy and interesting embracing
her natural body this makes me feel
strong and this makes me feel so lucky
to be a woman quote to this day my arms
shoulders breasts and thighs are fuller
I have a little mommy pouch and I'm in
no rush to get rid of it she also dished
on the birth complications she faced
with the Carter twins revealing she
developed toxemia and was on bed rest
for over a month
quote my health and my baby's health
were in danger so I had an emergency
c-section we spent many weeks in the
NICU as for her legacy the mother of
three wants to help create a more
inclusive culture for her kids for her
daughter's quote it's important to me
that they see themselves too in books
films and on runways and her hope for
her only son is to create better
representations for him so he is allowed
to reach his full potential as a man
[Music]
[Applause]